قسطنطين يفريموف
الملازم الروسي الكبير السابق الذي يطلب اللجوء
في الولايات المتحدة بعد خدمته في أوكرانيا ، وهو
أكبر ضابط يتحدث
بصراحة عما رآه هناك ، وأنا
أقدر وقتك الذي
شاركته معنا ببطاقة الهوية العسكرية الخاصة بك.
سأظهر للمشاهدين
الآن على الشاشة أنك عُينت
ملازمًا في عام 2017 ومن الواضح أنك
خدمت في أوكرانيا ، وأعلم أنك ما زلت تتحدث
مع الجنود الروس الموجودين هناك
يقاتلون الآن ماذا يقولون لك
عما يحدث على الأرض
جيدًا.  أن أقول إن هناك
عددًا قليلاً جدًا من الأشخاص الذين كنت على
اتصال بهم لأنك تستطيع أن تتخيل أن
مجرد التحدث معي يعرضهم بالفعل لخطر
كبير في الواقع بعد
هذه المقابلة وبعد الانفتاح فقط يمكنني أن
أتخيل غدًا أو ربما  كذلك
حتى اليوم سيتوقفون عن الحديث معي
وفي المرة الأخيرة التي تحدثت فيها معهم
لم يكن هناك الكثير الذي يمكنهم مشاركته معي
فقط الجوع والبرد هناك ظروف
ظروفهم قاسية للغاية تحاول
استقالة قسطنطين من الجيش أه
انتهيت  تم طردك لأنك
رفضت العودة إلى أوكرانيا
وأرسلوا لك مستندًا شاركته
معنا ودعوني أقرأ جزءًا منه
لمشاهدينا ، رفض رجل الخدمة هذا
الذهاب إلى أراضي أوكرانيا
لأداء خدمته ومهمته القتالية
لذلك ارتكب ملازم أول من AV
Constantine vladimirovic
مخالفة تأديبية جسيمة عبرت عن
تهربه من واجباته في الخدمة العسكرية ،
قسطنطين ، أنت الآن تأمل في التحدث
لطلب اللجوء في الولايات المتحدة ، لقد
غادرت روسيا ،
لماذا تعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة
يجب أن تمنحك  اللجوء
أعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية
هي بلد الديمقراطية حيث
ساعدت حقوق الإنسان وقد كنت بالفعل
في المكسيك لمدة شهر وخلال هذه
الفترة الزمنية كنت أحاول البحث عن
موعد مع الحراس الشخصيين
و  لسوء الحظ ، حتى الآن ذهبت جهودي
سدى ، وبالتالي
فإن المدافعين عن حقوق الإنسان
يدعموني في طلب اللجوء السياسي
[موسيقى]